So the question for you is, how many messages
are exchanged among all the nodes for each lock
acquisition followed by a lock release? Every process, what
it is doing is making a lock request and
it follows the algorithm that we just mentioned, uses
the lock in the critical section. And once it
is done with that, it unlocks by sending messages
again as you saw. And the question to you
is, how many messages are exchanged among
all the nodes for each lock acquisition followed
by a lock release? That is, combination of
lock plus unlock. How many messages does it
generate? Is it N minus one messages? 2 to the n minus 1? Or 3
to the n minus 1, where n is, the number of nodes in the distributed system.